okay um hey everyone thanks for coming
in um
uh we have michael walter here from the
university of amsterdam and all these
other lovely affiliations to uh
tell us about give us the second talk on
the hidden symmetries uh
part of the
thanks a lot cole um is the audio okay
for everyone
yes
thanks great
yeah thanks uh thanks everyone thanks to
the organizers for inviting uh uh
me to give i guess part uh part two of
this of this lecture series uh with avi
um apologies that i couldn't make it in
person um
surprisingly participating in a boot
camp uh did not appear to warrant a
national interest exemption or exception
to to fly over so uh that's how things
are currently
uh anyways i'm very happy to to to give
this talk um i mean it's about sort of a
line of work that really has uh
uh
has been developing very in very
interesting ways over the past years and
so let's jump let's jump right into it
so here's a recap of
parts of part one um of avi's talk
and so basically he showed us one
algorithm two class of problems and then
at the end were three questions and we
want to try to
address those questions in this in the
lecture
so the algorithm he discussed right was
auto demonization sort of a meta
algorithm that he you know would apply
to different problems and generally he
in general he spoke about two uh two
classes of problems right the first one
we're what we call scaling problems in
particular matrix scaling it's getting a
matrix by row and column
rescalings to be doubly stochastic
operator scaling was sort of this
quantum version uh tensor's getting not
i think it was maybe mentioned at the
end
maybe not in great detail but that also
exists so these are problems where you
have a mathematical object you want to
transform it in a way such that you know
it looks uniform in some sense for
example in the sense of having being a
doubly stochastic matrix
on the other hand in the last 10 or 15
minutes or so of his talk uh he also
discussed you know seemingly different
field in variant theory
um you know invariants flowing around
group actions um are you know
protagonists and uh there was one very
basic problem uh to which alternate
immunization also applied and this was
the problem of an alcohol membership
membership and alcohol um which you know
could be phrased
in in
the language of invariance or in a more
analytical language namely as asking
whether for a given vector uh whether
the uh orbits closure contains a zero
vector in other words can i sort of
squish the norm of my vector you know as
uh can i make the norm of my vector as
small as i want uh by applying uh the
group action okay
and the key to the analysis of these
algorithms turned out to be or sort of
it was slowly revealed that really
what's happening is that these
algorithms they move inside a group in
this case a group of product structure
and alternating minimization applied
and that you know in variant quantities
we're key to the analysis in one way or
another for example the permanent um you
know while not being a strictly left
invariant it does in fact the potential
function from the perspective of the
first of the first analysis you know it
transforms in a very controlled way
sometimes that you know that might be
called a semi invariant
um i guess then maybe some things we we
didn't get to talk about in the end uh
it turns out that invariant theory more
generally also provides powerful tools
to analyze the sort of the second
application uh named the snalcon uh uh
you know the application to the nalcon
problem uh basically by
by by giving us good balance on various
quantities and i hope this will be clear
later in the talk
so that's sort of you know a recap and
then the three questions that we were
left with were the following the first
one uh of course was you know why should
such a simple greed algorithm work i
mean greedy algorithms usually work if
there's additional structure now it has
of course already been you know
mentioned several times that the
structure will be a kind of convexity it
will be jdz context so that's something
we would like to see more clearly
the other question you know is why are
these what's the deal what's the
relationship between scaling problems
and this you know somewhat esoteric or
technical uh uh if you're not an
invariant theory is an outcome problem
okay so that's there is a deep
connection i would like to explain
what it is later in the talk
and then of course you know one reason
why you might want to ask these two
questions is so that you can also tackle
the third one namely going beyond
multilinear actions of product groups
right because only for those is it easy
to uh solve this individual these sub
problems in an alternating minimization
scheme and here's two examples where
alternative minimization uh
might not obviously apply um even though
you know there's maybe perhaps caveats
that we could discuss so one is
simultaneous conjugation so it's like
the left right action but you use the
same group uh from the left is to the
right so you do like your g times a i
times g inverse
um it's not there's only one factor now
so somehow if you had an alternating
immunization scheme you would have to
you know there's a single g ln so you
would have to sort of solve this the the
problem in one step so that clearly um
you know we can't do
another example would be if you want to
scale symmetric tensors while keeping
their symmetry so you would have a
tensor and you would again
scale by g tensor g tensor g and so on
if you did alternate immunization the
fact that you alternate between the tons
of factors will destroy the symmetry of
data so so these are just two examples
where you know alternate minimization
really isn't isn't good enough
so that's uh sort of the well the
starting point for this talk
and uh what i want to discuss indeed is
you know give maybe give you sort of a
high level overview of where you want to
go and what the connections are uh and
then you're not really setting the stage
what will come
zooming in
um then i want to sort of motivate why
you know what is this kind of connection
that we talk about it will turn out that
if the group is commutative we'll talk
about euclidean ordinary euclidean
convexity whereas if the group is not
commutative we'll talk about gdc
complexity
then somehow there's this duality
statement which really
the equivalence between scaling null
cone and another problem that we'll i
guess we've already heard the problem of
minimizing norms l2 norms
um and once you understand those
structural ingredients will then be very
easy to formulate algorithms not so easy
to analyze those um so we won't i'll
only sketch this um
and if time permits we'll uh also talk
about product tops i mentioned polytopes
it it turns out that not well it's maybe
not surprising that in a euclidean
convex setting you know convex
prototypes might appear it turns out
they even appear in this geodesic convex
setting where there's no obvious
euclidean convexity around and uh it
would be nice to have maybe we'll have a
few minutes to discuss that as well
all right so that's that's the plan
um and let me start with the big picture
that sort of you know shows all the
protagonists in this game so this is the
nalcon problem as it was you know one
one way of stating it that's sort of the
analytical way of stating if you want we
asking given a vector yes it's orbit
right you move along by the group action
there's an orbit we can close this orbit
and now we're asking is zero in that
closure or not so here it would not be
uh and generally that's a problem that
we might want to decide okay for example
we might want to decide this because we
are invariant theorists so we like
actually algebra and we want to ask an
algebraic problem which is equivalent to
this one and that's also something that
we mentioned that was actually his first
definition of an alcohol
so nalcon turns out to be exactly so a
vector v turns out to be the nullcone
exactly if it's indistinguishable from
the all zeros vector by any invariant
polynomial okay so if no invariant
polynomial can tell apart
a vector from the zero vector then and
only then it is non-alcohol okay so
that's a pretty algebraic question right
it seems to involve a fall quantifier it
turns out these invariant rings are
finely generated but that's not an
efficient way of going about solving
this problem so we are looking for new
ways okay and this new way of course is
by treating this
by looking at this formulation and
thinking about it as an optimization
problem so really what we want to do
here is we want to imagine we start with
a vector v
and then we just try to minimize this
norm staying inside the orbit and right
and if we can push the this norm all the
way to zero then we'll be in the
nullcone otherwise we can't so this
leads us to a tackling there's an
alcohol problem uh by a minimization or
phrasing it as a you know in terms of
minimization problem tackling it by
solving a you know
possibly harder problem a minimization
problem which is minimizing the norm of
g.v so this is the group actually
applied to this vector uh the norm is
always l2 norm in my talk uh over this
group okay
now whenever we're faced with a
minimization problem the first thing you
might want to do is you know look at
critical points that's a necessary
condition for minimality so
we might also want to do this here so
what we could do is we could say well
okay clearly one necessary condition for
being at a minimum is the gradient
of this objective function as a function
of g right of the group element which we
use to move along the orbit is equal to
zero for a minimum or close to zero for
an approximate minimizer
so we
might want to discuss what this gradient
means i think maybe on monday it was
already explained um so so that's maybe
already clear but we'll come back to it
concretely in a moment
um it turns out that we might therefore
want to you know start attacking this
problem and therefore an outcome problem
actually starting this one the problem
of basically minimizing gradients
now there's two magical things that
happen the first magical thing is that
these gradients they have sort of their
own relevance as we'll see in examples
in three examples at least it turns out
that these gradients exactly you know
they do you know as concrete and useful
things as computing row and column sums
computing margins of quantum operators
and doing all other kinds of
marginalization procedures
so the setting the gradient to zero is
not just a sort of a tactical um tool
and you know uh sort of if you have the
the larger dream of minimizing a norm
but it's actually often the other you
know the problem of prime interests
so we can think of this problem of you
know minimizing gradients actually as
you know a very general scaling problem
and we'll see how it you know
materializes say for matrices in a
moment
uh now that's the first magical thing we
actually care about this problem of
minimizing the gradient so we give it a
name you call it the scaling problem and
later we'll also give this gradient a
name we'll call it a moment now
the other magical thing is that actually
minimizing the gradient is going is
going to be equivalent to minimizing the
norm and that follows by a jedis context
property okay and so that gives us sort
of the
panorama and then the following you know
we want to zoom into this into this more
there's also a last connection you know
i mentioned that you know this gradient
will do things like computing row and
column sums now it's an interesting
problem to
make the you know make grown column sums
um uh you know uniform let's say
um but you know more generally we might
want to scale our matrix to general
marginals and we could ask you know what
are all the possible marginals that we
can scale a matrix to it turns out
that's one way in which polytopes appear
namely the set of you know possible
marginals r comma c to which we could
scale a matrix and you know analog a
statement in very large in height and
very large generality um actually uh
form uh convex polygons okay
and so that's that's sort of explaining
this picture more detail this is sort of
the ambition for the next 50 minutes
all right
uh so let's start slowly and let's just
recap our setting and i'll try to be
concrete to the sort of um you know
with the danger of being cartoonish and
you might think that you know the soul
theory only applies to glenn um glenn is
very you know important example and you
know more generally we look at things
like you know sln determine one
invertebrate matrices or what's called
an entourage so that's say diagonal n by
n matrices or you know just n tuples of
numbers which from a group just by
component by multiplication or uh but
i'm not sure what might have appeared in
aries talk stn which is determinant one
diagonal matrices and by entire matrices
so these are the kind of groups and
maybe products of those that we'll care
about in this talk but the whole theory
generalized to aesthetic that we we
might have time to to mention or we
might not and then we could discuss it
after the talk
so suppose you have such a group and it
acts on a fine dimension vector space by
linear transformations in a reasonable
way uh then you know with this data come
orbits so that's the set of all vectors
you can obtain from a fixed vector v by
applying the group action and orbit
closures as you saw in the last talk
here's a simple example a c star so just
a you know non-zero complex numbers act
on two-dimensional complex vector space
c two uh by you know multiplying by g in
the first component component and by g
inverse in the second component what did
the orbits look like well clearly the
product of x and y is invariant under
selection so um that gives us you know
generic orbits where x y equals some
constant for example here x times y
equals one would be this blue
hypersurface or it's a projection of the
rear to r2 here
or is its intersection of the r2
um but there's also other orbits right
so so this this blue orbit would be a
closed one but this green orbit well the
screen
the horizontal axis without the origin
turns out to also be orbit it's the
orbit of one zero and it's not closed
right because it contains zero in its
closure
so the point one zero would be an
example of something in the null cone uh
the point one one or any you know two
nonzero coordinates uh would be
something that is not in an outcome okay
so now we discussed we want to tackle
this now problem by studying uh you know
by minimizing norms and uh so let's give
you know
this this protagonist a name so let's
denote the
minimum l2 norm in the closure of an
orbit of an orbit through vector v let's
call this the capacity and denote it by
cap okay so cap of a vector in such a
general setting is just the infimum of
the norm as we move along the orbit or
the minimum of the norm as we move along
the old closure
okay and that's the basic optimization
problem that we want to solve and it
turns out that it does actually you know
up to some mild
you know taking uh powers and or uh and
roots and so on it actually coincides
with you know matrix question which i'm
not sure was mentioned for normal
capacity and operator capacities to go
with this capacity so they are basically
the same thing in disguise but it's not
obvious from the formulation
okay
so that's the thing we want to compute
our approximate our basic optimization
problem our primal problem if you wish
so to get a sort of a feeling for this
uh i want to look first at commutative
groups again those are usually called
tori so i do a taurus um
not clear why they're called toray at
this point
um and let's actually revisit you know
matrix scaling from this mindset i think
maybe this also addresses some questions
that were there before you know should
we look at complex matrices should we
look at major positive entries l2 norm
and one norm right so here i want to set
it up in the complex setting so i know
my group will be uh two pairs of n by n
diagonal matrices
uh invertible diagonal matrices so t n
times d n
and i want to act on complex n by n
matrices by you know scaling the rows by
the g's and the columns by the h's right
so that's the group action that we want
to study
now we could ask what is capacity here
so what's the minimum norm let's try to
find an expression for this
so let's look at the norm square because
that's nicer right normal square would
be just a
some of the squares of the entries uh
well we are risking growth by the gs
that comes by the h's so that's simply
the sum of squares that's sum of i j
absolute value g i m i j h j absolute
value squared
now if you were to carry out this
optimization problem the first thing you
would notice is that it's well
we don't need the richness of the
complex numbers um because we anyways
taking the absolute value squared so we
could make a change of variables right
and we could say well absolute value of
g i squared we'll just call e to the x i
and similarly absolute value h j squared
we call e to the y j
and so we then arrive at this
reformulation here in female x y which i
know real vectors they are the exponents
of these e to the x is e to the y js
and we arrive at this function and
minimizing this function is just is
completely equivalent to computing this
capacity squared okay so it's just this
l2 norm in this case
uh so it turns out that this function
sum of exponentials is convex in x and y
it's even log convex and you know it's
what we're doing here is really an easy
example of a geometric program
right
um
and so that's nice right so there's
convexity after a very simple chain of
variables we just you know write our
group as e to the x and then it's convex
and x so that's nice
now let's take one one one other step um
and uh you should not tell me at this
point that this theme was zero although
that's the case
um let's take another step and compute
gradients okay so what's the gradient
well let's compute the gradient at x
equals y equals zero because we kind of
want to know is our matrix already
minimizing the norm
um well if you do so clearly um in the
first if you take derivatives respect to
the x it's right you're summing over the
js if you take the root specifically
back to the yj's or something over the
axes so what's happening here is that
the gradient is simply computing row and
column sums
and if we compute the logarithmic
gradient we are going to get normalized
row and column sums or in other words
row and column sums of the matrix with n
whose entries are absolute value squared
of m i j divided by the whole frauvenia
squared okay
so
this is of course in matrix now with
non-negative entries so that's how the
transition from your complex matrices so
you know matrices non-negative entries
happens where l1 l2 norms get translated
now intel one knobs okay l1 norm after
taking squares
okay
so that's uh that's great okay uh now we
do one small modification and then the
technical slide is done the modification
we do is um instead of looking so why do
i want to do a modification okay so i
mean first of all it's great that our
gradient computes growing column sounds
so it confirms what i asserted before
that we like gradients we like gradients
of non-squares unfortunately we don't
want to set this gradient to zero but we
rather want to make it uniform if we
want to scale to adopt the stochastic
matrices
so we have to modify the group in such a
way that we get a condition for uniform
scaling for doubly stochastic scaling
and not for making the matrix zero
and that can be done simply by imposing
the condition that these diagonal
matrices here should have determined
once we call this st n
so what happens then well the thing that
changes is that now the
if we make the same variables as before
now the components of x and of y have to
sum to zero okay so in other words like
the traceless vectors if you want those
sum equals zero vectors in rn okay so
it's a subspace and hence also the
gradient will live in the subspace and
what will happen is simply that we we
subtract you know the something
proportional to the all ones vector to
make the resulting thing traceless
and so now we are happy right because
setting the gradient to zero means
making the rows and column sums uniform
which means making our matrix w
stochastic up to a factor one over n if
you wish okay
so this slide i hope shows very
concretely that you know for matrix
scaling uh normal minimization for a
natural group action and matrix scaling
the task of you know setting making the
rows and columns uniform are a complete
equivalent
and it maybe gives the first motivation
why you know sim because of this
convexity this log convex seed i
mentioned here um and maybe that gives a
first indication why synchron you know a
simple agreed algorithm like synchron
should solve these problems
well so both of these problems
um and in fact i mean the idea that one
should use this potential function or
the logarithmic or you know slight
variant of it it's a starting point for
you know cutting edge algorithm for
matrix skating that you know achieve
better guarantees than synchro
so that's what i wanted to say about
matrix scanning
all right
now i want to do one more example it
will look very similar i mean so i'll be
a bit quick but it's interesting because
it's some sense generic
so the next example i want to look at is
i'm going to look again at when this
times only n by n diagonal matrices not
a pair but a single environ diagonal
matrix group of environmental matrices
centaurus hectic and laurent polynomials
and n variables okay so laurent
polynomial is a polynomial where the
exponents are allowed to be integers not
just but not natural numbers and i use
this notation z to the omega for that
one to the omega one the two to the
omega two and so on so omega's exponent
vector here okay
and the way the group acts is simply
well it's just rescaling you know
monomial and the obvious way so c ones
can be scaled by g one z two is by g two
and so on and so forth okay as before we
can compute capacity which is the norm
square such a polynomial
and then the minimum norm square as we
as we you know apply group elements g
um and so well the norm absolute values
square of these coefficients what is p
omega of the value squared g omega
absolute value square we make the same
change of coordinates you know e to the
x we call we call this e to the x uh
sorry we call g as the value the entries
of of this group element g absolute
value squared we call e to the x
and now well this uh expression here
then simply becomes e to the x dot omega
right where omega is again one of these
exponent vectors x is an arbitrary real
vector the same chain of variables as
before for the same reason well again
this is a geometric program so it's
going to be log convex variable x
um and so that's nice okay so what do we
learned from this so here's a simple
observation when is this capacity equal
to zero so when can i make this quantity
as small as i want okay
so clearly that's possible if i can find
a vector x a direction x that has a
negative inner product with all of these
omegas okay
so now um
and it turns out that's that's the case
if and only if i can find such x in
other words x is sort of you know
determining a hyperplane that separates
the origin
from the convex hull of these weights
omega
so that means that capacity zero if and
only if zero is not in the convex hull
of these exponent vectors that actually
appear in the polytope equivalently
capacity is positive if and only if this
point zero is in this convex hall of
exponent vectors and that's exactly
what's called the newton polygon
so we see again for this very simple
group action there's interesting things
happening you know there's an
interesting geometric program
generalizing matrix scaling um there's
polytopes appearing here it's a you know
standard definition newton polytope of a
of a polynomial normal polynomial
um and again we can compute the gradient
by similar reasoning as before the
logarithmic gradient at x equals zero
well we'll just pull down write these
omegas so we'll get you know sum over p
omega squared omega divided by sum of
squares so that's a convex combination
right of these exponent vectors omega
that appear so clearly this gradient is
a point in this newton positor of the
polynomial and it turns out it's not
completely obvious but true that as we
you know move along the group orbit
these gradients actually sweep out the
entire polytroph up to some closure okay
so this polytope in some sense is you
know implicitly described by gradients
of a long polynomial
okay
and so the reason why i want to show you
this example is because it's essentially
universal for commutative group actions
in our setting so any um
you know nice uh commutative matrix
group of the form we'll consider any
reductive such group is essentially an n
by n taurus up to some change of
variables so really laurent and any
representation of such a such an
environment
environment
is essentially uh you know similar to an
action on normal normals
if you know why i'm lying you also know
why maybe it's okay to to lie here so
the point is that okay there's convexity
it's revealed after change of variables
okay basically going from r plus to r
um and it already gives a bunch of
interesting examples including matrix
scaling right and so recognizing this
geometry this convex geometry which is
actually a simple example of a geodesic
convex geometry
is sort of key to actually cutting out
algorithms
all right so that's uh that's a
commutative situation so now we want to
uh continue um and you know ask about
the non-commutative setting
uh so what should we do there and what i
want to do is just sort of proceed by
analogy and see what happens so
again the function you want to minimize
is the norm or norm square or i will
actually take the log norm the log norm
has the advantage that you know this
objective function is bounded from below
if and only if capacity is positive
right if and only
the vector is not an algo but some since
this problem is feasible if you want uh
exactly if you're not in an alcohol but
you can also just think of it as a
technical thing or you could say it's
motivated by the fact that in our
commutative examples even the logarithm
of the norms of the norm uh was uh was
convex right so maybe the same is true
and uncommitted
so to get a handle on the non-communist
situation let's look at the simplest
group gln um supposed group in our
setting glen
now any general linear matrix has a
polarity position meaning you can write
it as a unitary times a positive
definite matrix and it's reasonable to
assume and we can always in our setting
assume that actually unitary group acts
unitarily meaning it actually just it
does not change this norm okay in that
in this case we can restrict the
optimization
um from glenn to if you want gln module
un or you know
more concretely to the positive
different matrices
so instead of locking the whole group
you only look at the positive definite
elements in the group
so here any such element of course we
can write as e to the x where x is
hermitian right that's a complete
analogy to what i did before before we
had you know positive real numbers
as the only relevant part of c to the n
or c star to the n
and then positive real numbers we wrote
as e to the x for a real vector x and
now we do the same non-commutatively so
we look at take permission matrices
instead of real numbers
so after those change variables now we
can take a naive gradient and we could
uh um you know say okay that's probably
the right note of a gradient that will
give us this first order condition right
um so that would be very
complete analogy to what i did before
right before i always computed the
gradient of the logarithm of the norm
square or a logarithm of the norm at x
equals zero okay so i could do the same
let's take this log norm e to the x now
this matrix exponential of a matrix
which matrix x must take the gradient x
equals zero
that's right hermitian matrices are real
vector space so that will give me um a a
a uh
uh hydrogen and by n matrix as a
gradient okay so that's sort of the
pedestrian definition if you want
now the only thing i'm doing here which
i want to emphasize is i'm changing
perspective a little bit instead of
you know thinking of if i thought of
this if i compute the gradient here i
would ask you know what's the base point
what i want to do is i want to always
fix the base point at the point at which
i take the gradient to be the identity
element of the group or the x equals
zero vector right because e to the
zero's identity
uh but what i wrote but what i want to
do is i want to allow this
this this point that defines the orbit
to move okay
and so the function defined in this way
so the function mu that sends a nonzero
vector uh to the gradient of the log
norm function around the identity right
so that's really saying what is this
thing doing it's it's a gradient you
know sort of pointing to where the log
norm changes in the vicinity of this
vector v
if you stay in the orbit this thing is
called the moment map okay
and i again i gave you the pedestrian
definition i could have also said you
know uh the positive definite matrices
they have a natural remaining geometry
uh we discussed them i think monday
and so we can just take a remaining
gradient um you know add the identity
element of the positive definite
matrices
of our objective function f
okay so it's a remaining gradient at the
identity so how does my vector how does
the norm change changes and move along
the orbit as a function of the space
point here okay
okay so there's a bit of a mouse for
this definition but it's really
analogous to what i computed in the case
of matrix getting in the case
now where does this name moment or
momentum map come from it comes from
physics right it turns out so it
originated in hamiltonian mechanics and
classical mechanics um where it turns
out that you know symmetries uh
um sort of give rise to conserved
quantities by newton's theorem and
things like you know linear momentum
angular momentum and so forth uh are
special cases of this construction okay
but it's
sort of more generally but then i mean i
guess there's appear in physics that
have been sort of abstracted in
mathematics and the setting of syntactic
geometry and i imagine we'll hear more
about this in the next two lectures uh
by by nishite and jonathan okay
now why do we care okay so before we saw
that this gradient this you know
logarithmic gradient computed
interesting things like row and column
songs or you know points in a newton
polytoken
it turns out that in great generality in
all the examples that you know abby
mentioned or you know would have
mentioned if you had you know had more
time you know or two more lectures uh
this gradient captures interesting
information and setting the gradient to
zero which i right here just want to say
as you know setting mu to zero which i
here denote by setting mu to zero this
captures natural scaling problems and
you know if the group is non-cumulative
it's going to be non-commutative scan
groups like operator scaling
the story i told you here is for gln
right and uh
how did the group interval any you know
positive definite element in gln i can
write is e to the x for hermitian matrix
x how about products well we just take
pair you know tuples of formation
matrices how about things like sln well
to get a determinant one positive
definite matrix i want to exponentiate a
traceless transmission matrix so that's
same story and similar to how we
subtract an identity multiple of the
identity before
okay very good so
let's maybe uh do another and hopefully
that's the last of the painful
calculations let's look at operator
scaling so operator scaling
again relied on the left right action so
we have two copies of g line two pairs
of inverting matrices acting on d tuples
of n by n complex matrices so here
everything even an obvious talk was
complex we don't have to do some crazy
uh taking absolute value squares
and the action is what's called the left
right action so gh acts on a tuple of
matrices d tuple of matrices by you know
multiplying all of these matrices from
the left by g and from the right by h i
take h inverse to get a nice group
action but doesn't really matter you
could take transpose you could take h
not worry okay
now what's the norm okay of such a
matrix tuple as we apply a group element
um so the norm right well that again we
take l2 norm for matrices that means
trobanus norm and if if i2 would be just
the the the some the norm squared of
such a tube is simply the sum of square
of the individual for venus norms
uh if we you know write this out right
we have you know trace of this thing
star times trace of this thing and we
can again make a change of variables um
you know just like we said we've
indicated before and we can see now that
uh well g star g we can write this e to
the x and h star h we can write this to
the y and so we get this expression and
maybe there's a factor of two uh you
know off from relative to the previous
slide but i hope that's okay
so i'm doing the
the same change of variables as i did
before
and now with matrices submission
matrices instead of real vectors and i
get this nice objective function here
right and i can compute the gradient and
now we use this fancy word we call it
the moment map okay so the moment map at
point m
is the gradient of this function at x
equals y equals zero how does this norm
square change in the vicinity of that as
you move along the orbit
okay we're going to take a logarithmic
gradient so it's going again going to be
normalized by the
one over the
l2 norm squared uh but the crucial point
of course if i take the this gradient uh
with respect to x you know at x equals y
equals zero
then you know this thing is just the
identity matrix so it vanishes
and uh x just you know is pulled down
right by by taking the derivative so
what i get is you know is is exactly sum
over i m i m i star stars the hermitian
conjugate
likewise the component the y component
of the gradient will be a negative
because the minus here sum of i am i
star mi okay and that's because of you
you use you know x is zero so it just
vanishes and you use simplicity to move
the mi over okay and that's exactly this
weird sum of squares but in an obvious
you know notion of what it means to
scale an operator a quantum operation
okay a quantum channel a completely
positive map okay
and again we can we can restrict to sln
times sln which will mean that we look
at traceless emission matrices so we'll
subtract the tracial part here and after
and once we have done this then you know
minimizing the gradient or equivalently
setting the moment map to zero is
exactly exactly captures operator
scaling okay
so that's fantastic it seems like you
know
non-minimization you know gives rise to
operator scaling in very natural way
but there's a slight challenge here and
the challenge of the catch is that
actually this objective function here is
not a convex function of x and y in the
usually euclidean sense okay and that's
where we have to be a little bit careful
so you know it's not convex nevertheless
you know
two talks have claimed that these uh
minimizing the norm and minimize the
gradients are equivalent problems so we
have to change the geometry we're
looking at it wrong we should look at
your cleaning geometry and it turns out
that that's indeed what's going on so
why does the equivalence that has been
asserted between normal minimization
scaling white as a told it holds because
our objective function restricted to the
positive definite matrices like i'm
doing here is convex a long a long
curves of the form e to the x t for any
fixed x right so rather than looking at
uh convexity you know on all the
hermitian matrices i'm looking at these
curves through the identity matrix okay
and these are indeed geodesics for
natural riemannian metric on ptn okay
so
f in other words is a judicial convex
function okay and i guess here was a
little picture of what such a curve
looks like um sadly this a should be
have been an x apologize for not
updating this
but that's the situation okay so we are
we still have these curves e to the x t
we are convex along those
and what's nice is that clearly i can
get from the identity to any positive
definite matrix by such a curve right
because i can write any positive
definite matrix e to the x
so clearly they're connected to the
identity and so this connectedness um
the fact that you know any two points
are connected in fact by unique geodesic
uh makes the theory work really nicely
you know almost as nice as in the
euclidean case
so why does this geodesic convexity hold
i mean one
way of seeing this is to do a
calculation here's sort of a more
abstract argument that's basically
correct and basically i'm not lying and
the idea is that well we want to
restrict to such a curve e to the x t
where x is fixed and t is some parameter
okay
now subject curve is also a commutative
subgroup but and i kind of told you that
any community subgroup is kind of like a
tourist right so here it will be a one
dimensional one i'm lying a little bit
but again that's okay
so for for for nice x that would be the
case in general e to the x g will
generate some tools okay
but we know that in the commutative case
right in this commutative case any
action is equivalent i told you two
lower polynomials and for long
polynomials we know that if we minimize
a norm square that we get a
geometric program which is log convex
so
it follows at once uh that this log norm
even a non-computer setting is judassi
connects because that gear does convex
it simply translates into convexity
whenever we look at commutative
subgroups okay
such as the one generator basically xd
okay
now euclidean i know now just a
convexity we learned uh earlier this
week it's nice right for example here
because everything is connected by
unique genetics and so on we can really
compare any two points it's not like
different connected components or
anything
um critical points therefore are
you know not only a global minima
critical points but also also the
converse is true in other words if you
have a vector that's you know
has the smallest norm in its orbit in
other words its norm equals its capacity
capacity is the smartest norm in the
overclosure
then and only then is the gradient at
this point zero and the gradient at this
point right is exactly what we call the
moment map mu of v
so you know in this sense normal
minimization and scaling are equivalent
it's a very um rigid kind of sense right
because i have strict qualities here and
that's something we'll have to fix
um but sort of you know it gives the
first glance where i think should be
okay maybe we'll be okay
no
now if one month yep
let me know if you can hear me if not i
can grab the microphone uh i just was
curious so is the notion of gradient
you're working with here
um it's the same gradient as you were
working with before it's not the one
induced by this romanian structure where
you get the convexity
um
it's yeah it's it's the same it's the
same i mean there's e to the x right it
changes basically i mean e to the x is
kind of normal coordinates but uh
around the identity so taking this naive
gradient at x equals zero
is the same as as the remaining gradient
with respect to this nice you know uh
romanometric um that's not the euclidean
metric on on pdn okay so the gradients
coincide
yeah yeah yeah thank you
thanks
yeah so it's important that this course
here go through the identity right
otherwise i would have like little
spirit of peace sitting around um
if i wanted to go in a have a different
base point
great
um so so that's that's great so now we
have a g convex g so we can hope for
nice things to happen but if you want to
make things concrete right we have to
understand you know how just how convex
our objective function is so and what i
mean by this is that you know in
ordinary conduct optimization um there's
you know a rich toolbox and there's lots
of function classes you know
well condition functions smooth
functions which functions what not and
right for either of these we know how to
do how to analyze various algorithms so
we could ask you know what kind of nice
properties does this log norm function
satisfy in generality i mean i write it
here for pdn actions of gln but
what i'm saying will generalize
so how convex
in quotes is you know is our objective
function our log norm function for any
given action surely it will depend on
the action right if you have a very high
degree action it will probably not be as
continuous as you know one that's linear
and so on and so forth
so um here are some things that we know
okay and sort of the idea is you know we
look at the toolbox of ordinary connect
experimentation and we
we generalize the geodesic settings
simply by you know
saying something has you know geodesic
property p if property p holds along all
genetics okay
and um
in this present setting it suffices to
look at geodesics through the identity
so things that the coffee form e to the
xd okay
and so for example one thing that is
true is that this objective is
geodesically smooth okay meaning that
second derivatives are not only you know
convexity would mean they're lower
bounded by zero right a hessian
spd psd um here the hessian
has the largest eigenvalue l right or
gradients ellipses continuous if you
want or another way to say it is that
yeah a long along you know any geodesic
e to the xt or any just form e to the x
t if i take second derivatives this is
upper bounded by some constant l times
and okay now comes the norm square of x
because the norm of x kind of tells me
you know how fast i move along its
status so unit speed would kind of be
norm of x equals one and but of course
there's sort of a
yeah
i mean a natural scaling by the size max
here so that's the geodesic version of
smoothness and it holds here and the
value of l depends on the action maybe
i'll come back to it maybe not
so that's one thing that's useful right
so now we can immediately apply what i
think nikola told us on monday uh we can
apply you know the analysis for
gradients and for smooth functions
okay
um
it turns out that okay more is true okay
so smoothness is great but actually you
know what we care about i presented to
you this you know this big picture at
the beginning with lots of errors and
equivalences that i inserted and i
assert together that scaling and
normalization so no minimization and
gradient minimizations are equivalent
now to really you know make this
algorithmically equivalent what i need
to know is you know if i'm close to the
optimum in the primal problem in
non-minimization am i close to the
optimum in the dual problem that is you
know is my gradient small
and that's something that one can show
and one side is easy for some smoothness
the fact that gradient steps make
progress the other side is quite a bit
harder
and so here's the result here's sort of
the result that we could show
which kind of makes this old theory i
mean this genetic connection goes back
you know to the late 70s uh you know
makes it for the first time quantitative
and you know use usable analysts
and so what we're looking at here right
we're looking here at the you know sort
of the gap in the primal program
it's sort of a multiple multiplicative
one so this is the minimum norm squared
divided by the norm squared our current
point v
now this quantity is always less equal
to one right it's close to one if you're
close to the minimum
so if you could somehow say that this
quantity is close to one if and only if
the gradient is small you would be happy
right you would say oh i'm my primal gap
is small if and only if my dual gap is
small
and that's exactly what's happening here
right because we see here that here we
have the norm of the gradient divided by
some constant norm of the gradient
squared divided by some constants so if
the gradient you know it's very small
the norm is close to how small it can be
and vice versa okay so that's the
content of these estimates and they're
of course extremely useful in actually
analyzing algorithms
so what this shows this resolves several
you know puzzles perhaps
that you know at once so as we just
discussed it shows that normalization
scaling are equivalent in quantitative
way
uh it also shows actually that one can
solve the nullcone membership problem by
solving either normalization or scaling
okay so for nullcode membership i want
to know is this capacity 0 or not so
what i could do is i could just you know
try to minimize the gradient for example
by doing gradient descent and if i
manage to make the gradient smaller than
gamma then this left hand side is
strictly larger than zero so capacity
cannot be zero so i'm not in an alcohol
so this kind of reasoning uh can be you
know pushed uh further to a soft and
welcome problem
so
the absence of the square in the lower
bound
is that um
somehow not removable is this there's a
fundamental reason for it um good
question um it's something that has
concerned us but i don't remember now if
there's some
if there's some count example or not
maybe maybe uh
i'll be a cold to remember
that's a good question i think it's
necessary
i mean if it weren't
there i think we would have a lot better
algorithms okay right
yeah there is an obstacle
okay
thanks
uh great okay yeah so and the last thing
i want to i want to comment this i mean
what this also shows is that in
particular scaling is possible if and
only if you're not in the nullcone right
what is scaling the scaling problem what
was the scaling problem was setting
gradients to zero right and setting
gradient to zero of course can only be
can only happen if capacity is positive
on the other end if capacity is positive
just goes to the nor minimizer and the
gradient will be zero
so so that's you know these three
statements together they sort of you
know resolve the you know maybe
hopefully resolve this you know uh or it
they they prove to you or they convince
you that indeed all these problems we
mentioned are
related equivalent in a precise
quantitative way
now um
yeah yes yes
is there any like known alternative way
to completing like this result not
relying on like genius xp
um
i mean in the end uh the way we prove it
is in some sense
by studying you know the geometric
programs you obtain by restricting your
non-commuted group to all possible
commutative subgroups
um so in some sense you
you know you
you know if you just make this change of
variables e to the xt for any fixed x
you know you have a one dimensional
problem left in t
so i think that's good enough to uh to
to roughly speak improve these results
although you do have to know a little
bit about about group action so that's
actually one point also regards to a
question that was in the previous talk
uh how groups and representations come
in is sort of i mean gamma and l they
actually arise from group theoretic data
so if you have some concrete
representation you might you could
possibly work them out you know by hand
over the smart idea but there's a very
general recipe for how to compute these
you know these constants that arises you
know we can now we can as you read off
easily from the from the from the action
yeah so indeed so l and gamma so elvis
is the smoothest concern and gamma um is
another parameter uh they depend on if
you want commentarial data of the action
i think i will not have time to talk
about these for those of you who know um
they're related to what's called the
weight
weights of a representation it's a bunch
of integer vectors or points in the
lattices characterize representations of
reductive groups
um
in some sense yeah i mean maybe we'll
come back to that later you can ask me
about it but
but it's not so important point is like
with any group you can sort of associate
some combinatorical data a bunch of
integer vectors or points in their
letters and then with those points and
letters they're coming things like you
know what's the largest norm of these
these lattice points what's the smallest
you know some convex hull of lattice
points can go to zero and these kind of
gaps they determine exactly the
constants and and and this nc duality in
this non-communicationality statement
okay
okay cool so here's here's a summary of
the first part um
well a large part of the talk i i reckon
um so uh we call this non-creative group
demonstration but really what we're
doing is indeed when we're minimizing
norms of a group
of our group orbits for nice groups such
as gln nice subgroups of gln on fine
dimension vector spaces
we have this concept of a moment map
which which is really just a gradient
right at
at point b in the orbit through v
and this is part of the picture that we
already saw right we knock on problem
can be solved by doing no minimization
or scaling
scaling means setting the gradient to
zero normalization means about
minimizing norms these are equivalent
you know on a sort of a non-content in a
quantitative way but you convexity in a
quantitative way by these conceptuality
estimates that i showed you
and so this g convexity you know sort of
this underlying
is the underlying you know structure
that might motivate why a simple greedy
you know local algorithm
can can work with you know
rigorous guarantees
um
i mentioned that all these problems are
now related in a quantitative way so we
really know you know how small does this
have to be in order to solve that
problem for example
um maybe
i don't want to go into this too much at
this point but um
i guess we saw you know various uh uh
convex programming notions you know uh
appear when we discuss matrix scaling on
the example of the normal polynomials
um you know for example i basically said
in words things that amount to lp
duality when i spoke about when the
capacity or not so in a sense this
theory or this framework can be regarded
as a non-communicative generalization or
a geodesic convex generalization of some
of these things like lp duality and
facts about geometric programs
and all the examples that we discussed
and also the ones that he had on his
slides that did not discuss uh basically
fall into the framework in one way or
not so that's uh that's really nice
okay um so now uh
we could talk about you know
what is really the set of the class of
groups for which we can carry out this
theory
um maybe i'll just tell you what it is
to to sort of satisfy your curiosity but
not why it works so the set of groups is
basically here's a concrete description
so they're called complex reductive
groups they're basically subgroups of
gln that are defined by polynomial
equations for example sln is defined by
the polynomial equation determinant
equals one inside gene
and we want this group to be closed
under taking adjoints so you know
emission conjugates are again in the
group
if you have this then basically
everything i wrote before works very
concretely
and um
yeah the analog of you know passing from
gln to the positive different matrices
is now passing from this group g so the
positive matrix inside this group
and that turns out to be in you know
in this generality hadamard manifolds or
you know symmetric space of non-compact
type uh so what this is a remaining
manifold that has curvature and the
curvature is non-positive
so it's then it has a single coordinate
chart into the x like we saw before so
it's it's one of it's it's a very tame
such manifold but nevertheless it has
non-positive curator which makes things
challenging okay
that's sort of maybe interlude for for
for the experts
now i think i uh if i remember right
when we started i have maybe about 10
minutes left i want to talk a little bit
about algorithms and we'll see if we
talk about polytopes the good thing
about talk about with regards to talking
about algorithms is that we there's not
so much to talk about right because we
already established all the you know
technical basics
so for example our function is smooth
and has the smoothness parameter so
clearly one thing we could do is we
could run gradient descent with step
size one or well as as was explained i
think on monday okay
so you know so that's great in this end
right you have your current group
element g that you know moves you from a
starting vector to where you want to go
um and you just update it in this case
by left multiplying and you do a little
step and okay here it's like a little
gd6 steps you used exponential map and
you
to move along uh the direction of the
gradient and the gradient is of course
the same as the moment map at the point
where you currently are that's how the
moment where mu was defined as the
gradient at point gb
okay so that's gradient descent and one
can show um that uh for a vector that's
not in the null cone and that's exactly
when scaling is possible to arbitrary
accuracy
uh gradient descent works it finds a
group element for any epsilon finds a
group of g such that the gradient the
moment at this point is epsilon small
and thus so you know s1 expects and
probably one over epsilon steps and uh
there's you know other dependence on the
input size input size it means
description of the group of the
representation of the input vector v
uh yeah everything except appstore
how this one analyzes well the
standard part is sort of the you know
how to use smoothness and analyzing
gradient descent so it makes you trust
gradients right
if you don't look go too far
and you can combine this uh again that
gives you one bit and then somewhere
there has to be something problem
specific and the problem specific part
is a priori lower bounds and capacities
if capacity is non-zero one can show
it's only exponentially small
and uh i i'm not sure how we got around
to saying this i think he had it on his
slides this we obtain and that's
actually sort of the the non-trivial
input from from again so that's like a
second input from group theory uh and
here we use constructive invariant
theory to basically say so basically
ideas if you can construct invariants
that are not too complicated and they
witness that our vector is not in the
nullcone then this can be obtained to
obtain well this can be used to obtain
bounds on capacity up to your rebounds
and that's what's needed here
i explained before that you know we can
solve the nulcon problem by choosing uh
you know making the gradients small
enough maybe smaller than uh
gamma that's this this constant and the
uh nc duality estimates and so indeed
the same algorithm can solve an outcome
problem in time probably one of the
gamma and the input size but now gamma
is one of these you know combinatorial
constants that depend on the action
um simply by running gradient descent
okay and so the idea is um
uh well if you're not in the null cone
then you can achieve this right
if you just run gradient descent until
you have this guarantee right that works
by the theorem but if you are in the
null cone you can make your gradient
never smaller than gamma by these nc
duality estimates okay
so either way you win so you just run
gradient and if you you know sort of
assuming that you are not in the null
cone and then you check if your grade is
indeed below gamma so that's the idea
so that's a first order algorithm
um there's also a second order algorithm
about which i'll be even more vague so
here's the idea so this is sort of of
the trust region or a box constrained
newton method type
um
here what we do is we we well we look at
local quadratic approximations on some
neighborhood where we can trust such a
pragmatic quadratic approximation uh we
have to regularize the objective but
okay that's maybe a detail
um and then if one doesn't right because
the quadratic method you can maybe hope
for for log one of epsilon uh
convergence and that's i think the case
so we can show that if uh again we start
you know with a vector that's not an
alkone meaning the scaling problem is
solvable for any epsilon or normal
minimization has you know it's uh it's
possible to you know non-zero norm in
female capacity is nonzero in this case
you get an additive approximation
epsilon additive approximation to the
log capacity so f is the log norm right
so that's that's this log capacity i
should have written this uh within the
number of steps is the log one epsilon
poly log one of the sun input size but
now again this constant one of our gamma
accretes it okay and so why is this well
how do you analyze that's the procedure
for such a trust region method well you
have to know you know what's the size of
a region that you can trust and you have
to know the diameter of the sub-level
set up found on the diamond subway set
the size of the neighborhood turns out
to also depend on this on this quantity
l which i did not call weight norm but i
might have if i wouldn't have skipped
this light
so that was the thing that determines
smoothness it also determines what's
called robustness and
sort of recent optimization literature
um
and you know this this up your rebound
on the diameter we
obtain in sort of an entry away
but sadly we use nc duality along the
way so we pick up a one over gamma okay
so that's kind of what we get and i
guess i should say okay how should we
feel about gamma and how should we feed
about l for some reason l never appeared
in in my in my uh time
time iteration balance right
only gamma appeared at various points
and the reason is that l is harmless
it's usually a polynomial in the input
size or at this point in the input size
but this weight margin can be
exponential okay and that really depends
on the action so it turns out that you
know um for nice nice situations like
matrix operator skating tensor skating
by one dimensional sticks
uh certain quivers and what not um
gamma is only probably large so we have
polytime algorithms but say for tensors
for tensor scaling or for um yeah
non-uniform operator skating in case we
don't get there anymore uh actually
gamma is exponentially large and so
that's that's a challenge okay so that's
so basic these songs i showed pretty
here in some sense the state of the art
of what we know how to do they sort of
they subsume you know sort of previous
work and say
uh you know matrix operators game
alternate minimization so these are not
alternative alternate immunization
algorithms anymore they do small steps
gradient steps or the second order steps
um they apply
much more generally of course the g to g
conducts optimization uh the only way in
which the problem enters is by diameter
bounds and you know a priori bounce
capacity about so on and we can use
either of them to solve normalization
scaling or nalcon problems
and indeed for many interesting uh
actions they are polytime but not always
not in all parameters
um so that's uh that's sort of uh
problem
okay
so um
i'm not sure if he started like five
minutes late so if i may i would still
maybe keep going for five minutes uh
cool do you allow
uh ill um i
i guess people can can vote for their
feet
yeah so maybe maybe i'll be pretty quick
so maybe i was just going to tell you
where these probably what's the deal
with these polytops right i mean they
seem to be tantalizing i mean everyone
likes polytons okay
so let's just go back to skating from
real quick so what does this gain
problem ask us to do it says given a
vector find a group element such that
your gradient is almost zero and
gradient almost zero or greatly equal to
zero right that means depending on the
context depending on the group action
doubly stochastic matrix an isotropic
frame you know a quantum doubly
stochastic
quantum operator in the case operator
scaling you know with these like m star
m equals identity m sum of m and star
equals identity or uniform marginals in
some more general settings so so kind of
mu equals zero in various contexts for
various actions you know means
kind of uniform aspects isotropic
aspects you know balancing
now
in general we don't only care about
uniform origins right for example for
matrix scaling we also care about rc
matrix dating with such you know we
where we prescribe row sums and columns
that are not uniform
and we might ask this problem in general
we might say you know given a vector um
and a you know target marginal p a
target p find a group element such that
you know our gradient or moment map
at that point is close to p
and p need not be zero
and we could systematize this by
defining an object delta of v that
captures all of these possible marginals
if you want that i can obtain
so this looks very abstract but for
example in the case of matrix scaling
what i'm saying here delta is simply the
set of all r comma c of all row sums and
column sums that can be obtained by
scaling a fixed given matrix
similarly for operator scaling similarly
in other settings okay
now if our group is commutative and we
are in this long polynomial setting we
saw before that gradients
the set of gradients or the moment map
sweeps out the newton polygon okay so
commutative setting is very simple we
simply get newton polytopes in various
disguises
in particular economics polito
what's rather amazing is that even
for non-cumulative group actions in the
generality we discussed
um one still gets convicted polytopes by
a slight twist of this definition
instead of yeah maybe i'll i'll say that
maybe yeah if you ask me about it so
slight definition of the slide twister
definition uh basically says that you
know this image of of of the set of all
possible gradients in the orbit closure
is basically just sweeps out the an
euclidean convex polito even though the
underlying geometry is g convex right so
that's super weird and quite magical
okay
and what's funny is that these these
polytopes are usually quite complicated
so um
they may have exponentially many
vertices of assets and in particular we
don't know these various surfaces
without thinking hard and then you know
doing difficult math
um even though the representation is on
a polynomial or space okay and so that's
of course concerning on the one inside
but it's also very cool right because it
allows you possibly to reason about
exponentially complicated objects you
know my polynomial time algorithm in
polynomial space
um so it's almost succinctly encoded
okay so um there's lots of examples uh
one matrix here already mentioned so one
of these moments so so yeah so this
thing is called a moment polytope and
it's basically a set of all in you know
values that the moment map can attain
so one example i mentioned matrix
scaling in this case it's the set of row
and column sums that can arise from
stating a fixed matrix m
another example of a polytope that
everyone knows is the the schwhorn one
so if you ask suppose i have a mission
matrix with fixed eigenvalues what are
the possible diagonal entries that such
a matrix can have
so that turns out to be the convex
perimeter heat drawn of lambda and i
think
the nishita or jonathan will talk about
it actually from a very different
perspective but it's the same thing and
you could try proving the results but
you could try characterizing this with
everything i've told you so far you
should be able to derive this result
and here's one non-trivial setting maybe
i'll open those in case you want a
glance but one nonchalant example is
following suppose you look at triple
formation matrix a b and c substitute a
plus b equals c okay and suppose you're
interested in what are the possible
eigenvalues of a b and c so what is the
angle of a angle of the angle c such
that for for any triple rate sheets
such that a plus b equals c permission
matrices okay so that's some subset of r
two three n which has no reason to be a
convex polytope it is a convex topic and
it's connected to lots of
mathematics i mean that's basically the
so
beautiful
famous horns formerly horns conjecture
and our theorem i guess of flutes and
tao establishes you know certain
inequalities that describe this this
problem
and it's very tantalizing also from
algorithmic point of view because we can
decide membership and polytime due to
result by kit anomaly
which is very non-trivial
and but but how to do how to actually
find pre-images
so solving this non-uniform scaling
problem or even solving the non-uniform
same problem is actually quite tricky
and i mean cold has a beautiful
algorithm which is not yet fully timed
all in all parameters so basically
non-non-community setting um uh yeah we
are sort of happy because they are
really cool and interesting and not very
well understood polytopes but sad
because the algorithms are not quite
there
okay so i'm not telling you how we can
do that but
one can reduce to to normalization by
some clever trick or twist
but let me just wrap up
so um i guess i i tried to talk to to
tell you about three things i think i
only managed to tell you about two and a
half but maybe that's okay
so i uh
the first message of this talk right was
sort of uh explaining the unreasonable
effectiveness alternative minimization
right and the key to explaining it is
the student has a convexity
of the norm or even log norm function
and that holds for very general group
actions like general reductive groups
and basically no assumptions on the
action okay and uh observing you know
this underlying structure this
underlying explanation is then also key
and as you saw right to finding general
algorithms that can then be based on
your general principle of judaistic
convex optimization okay
um and so that's right why it's you know
and interesting to to see these certain
symmetries to figure out what's the
right geometry so that then you know we
can tackle those problems beyond the
domain of applicability voltage
immunization the second message was that
gradients are cool i mean gradients here
are not a gradients here and not just
you know a thing that you use when you
minimize an objective function you know
the directions that you pick but they
have intrinsic meaning they capture
natural scaling or marginal problems
involving your joint distribution
matrices quantum states frames and so on
and so forth
um and then the set of possible
marginals we saw very quickly probably
too quickly uh can be encoded by actual
euclidean convex polytops so things like
this so-called moment polytopes and they
are cool because they're exponentially
complicated if you look at them naively
in terms of their description
by vertices of assets but sometimes we
can probe them efficiently using using
algorithms okay and you wish to do that
in a more general context
okay so there's lots of things we don't
understand we don't have time elements
in all parameters all actions
uh part of the reason is because
g-connect optimization on positive
curvature you know still lacking
compared to the euclidean setting
um we discussed this null cone problem
which we can now tackle here uh but you
know now that's not going problem is
like it's one you know out of like a
whole array of interesting computation
problems in variant theory
what about those and there's you know
first results for various actions can we
sort of do better can you systematize
those
and you know more generally of course
how can we tackle other interesting
problems maybe the computative pit
problem um that offsets its symmetries
yeah so thanks for attention and sorry
for running overtime and
even speaking to you online
thanks
any other questions
all right
okay
so uh did you take a vector
in this format that you consider 0 is
not there
is there any interpretation of the
minimizing point in terms of those
invariant polynomials
yeah
so basically if you take say a
homogeneous polynomial right so the
homogeneous pronoun would be zero at the
zero point and um
uh you take one that's non-zero right so
yeah so if you have such a situation
like a picture here
right you know that you can separate
this orbit
from zero by an invariant polynomial uh
let's take it to homogeneous or zero
here and you know non-zero on this on
this orbit uh it's it's i think it's
basically maximized it's basically
exponentially uh concentrated on the
point of minimum norm
so it's sort of it's like where the
invariant has you know this large has
largest
value
or a invariant here that sees that that
sees that witnesses the separation
yeah so i have a multiple
i'll start uh
the first one is uh so when you you so
you started with like fix v fix p and
you said uh for all uh given v what are
the p's that i can achieve right and
that was the
moment that
what avi talked about was the dual
question which is you fix uh p which in
this case was uh uh uniform marginals
and tell us that you know permanent
larger than uh strictly positive
president showed that you know v was
like matrices with strictly positive
permanence could get you there uh using
scaling so i wonder do we know anything
about the pre images of a particular
piece so you give me p and i ask you
what are the v's that can actually get
there by scaling
um
i mean maybe let me let me make sure i
understand uh
so
what what we said right is so if you
told you if the permit is non-zero then
you could scale to say uniform origins
right to a fixed p
um
that's that's what you said right yeah
so so the permanent here in this setting
you could think of as an
invariant polynomial in some sense right
i mean we we plug in these these
positive matrices but something that
doesn't change under change under
scaling by determining one matrices
so the
generalization of that statement would
be something like if you have a an
invariant polynomial that you know such
that p of b is not
not equal to p of zero so it separates
well it's separate zero
uh from the orbit then you can scale to
uniform originals so that's that's the
generalization of that statement
okay so
another i mean
the other question i think you asked
right
is sort of can we characterize those
uh vectors
for which the amount map is zero right
um
other p
i said like if you give me
oh yeah i see that's a marginal let's
see the sinkhorn setup and i i ask you i
see you wanna you wanna like know what
sort of the analog i'll say permanent
for rc scaling or something like this
that's right
that's right yeah so in in complete
generality um basically uh one has to
replace invariant polynomials by
polynomials that
transform in a certain way so um
sometimes people call them covariance so
i'm slightly lying but but maybe maybe
that's
that makes sense okay so so rather than
not changing so so not changing at all
kind of corresponds to the zero point
and so to you know moment map equals
zero and changing in in sort of a
controlled way say you know say you
apply your group element and then uh
what happens is your your function is
not does not stay in variant but it
actually changes like a determinant so
but but that's a scalar right then that
verse correspond for example to scaling
to all ones more notes so so and for
like for interesting points you know if
you really want to scale to margins that
you know are really i don't know like
five seven two one then five seven two
one i guess seven five two one
which would be say your row sums would
label um well say yeah would label a
certain representation of your group if
you want
and um
uh and uh and you kind of you are
looking for a polynomial or a bunch of
polynomials that transforms in this way
so it's not invariant but it it's it's
transforms in a controlled way and then
and only then can you solve the scaling
problem
so
yeah i'm yeah probably that that would
have been not nicer to write on a
whiteboard
um
but that's maybe one that's kind of the
general answer here
so basically uh all points in this you
know polytube of possible marginals
they're characterized by you know kind
of
uh
you know covariant polynomials so and
the origin corresponds to invariance
polynomials
and the
original yeah i had a question um first
question was you were talking about the
how you can use the the time
discretization of the gradient flow
either a first order or a second order
to design these algorithms and my
question was did you consider any
implicit time discretizations or or what
was the reasoning behind choosing an
explicit one for for example for the
first order one
um i think just uh
naivety i mean something that we knew
how to do um
speaking of gradient flows i mean i
think that doesn't maybe
fully address your question but what it
comes to mind is maybe interesting to
say actually when we prove these
diameter bounds or these uh yeah these
these standard amounts and relate
related things and you know bounce and
capacity is that we actually need to
make gradient descent effective we do
actually study the continuous gradient
flow
um to you know sort of numeric uh sort
of analytically sort of band
uh to get these bounds so maybe that's
that's interesting but that yeah that
would be then fully fully continuous
time though
um but yeah i mean i i would say uh
sort of other other algorithmic schemes
maybe
maybe mostly our naivety starting with a
simple scheme
uh one is consider other geometries um
taking the gradient with respect to
other geometries are there are there any
others that you know of that would be
natural to think of in this context um
but uh yeah other geometries for the
same in for the same objective function
uh yeah so it's always so that the
general setting is um yeah you take some
nice subgroup of gln
um yeah that's closed into hermitian
adjoins
and then you look at the positive
definite matrices in this group
so so these are always going to be
generalizations of pd matrices but for
example could be
you know if you uh your group actions by
sln then it would be determinant one pd
matrices right and that makes it already
clear that we should not look at the
euclidean geometry of the positive
different matrices because if we set the
turn one it's no longer a euclidean
convex set right um so but that i i
guess maybe that's still not so
interesting to erp i guess you're
looking maybe yet for for groups that
are not of the g line sln type there i
have to say
personally the only example that i know
are certain symplectic groups
and then there's also sort of the pd
elements in it
that one can study but but somewhat in
general these are always
they're always kind of they have a very
similar flavor i think like they're
always non-positively curved uh
manifolds
uh you know with a single coordinate
chart so such amount manifolds and they
are they are classified if you want you
know just so it turns out that the set
of groups that i mentioned before
even though it you know it looked very
flexible you know arbitrary subgroups
defined by tomorrow equations closed and
taking up joints
uh actually you can classify those
completely and therefore you know that's
also then a classification of these uh
these these spaces these geometries that
appear naturally in the setup
so for example a group that we
would not
um
would not necessarily know how to
optimize over i guess
one can imagine for example group of
upper triangular matrices
uh acting in a way that does not extend
to some you know to all of glm
and that may have a different flavor and
i don't know or yeah that may have a
different flavor
but somehow yeah for us it's always sort
of uh totally geodesic supplementals of
pdf basically maybe that's a good way of
saying it
yeah and and sorry i'll discuss one more
um other types of norms you talk about
the two convenience other other
functionals that you might consider to
optimize with respect to the same
geometric structure
uh great question yeah i mean i don't i
don't have anything to report although
um
uh
there are interesting things we're
thinking about but somehow here uh
yeah so far what i showed seemed pretty
kind of married to the l2 norm because
right we had some other
the altoona was right so i mean
some of the reason why i went i ended up
in pdn right was i could get rid of the
unitaries the unitary sort of the
unitaries in my group they would act
in a way that preserves the l2 norm so
that's by unitary so unitaries get
mapped to unitaries but so that's kind
of nicely canonical i'm not sure say
doing something like l1 or how that
would fit in but it's it's an
interesting question we've all we
thought about some other functionals
which are maybe not of the norm type
which would
which may appear here
but yeah i don't think i have a good
answer or
some complete proposal
all right let's thank michael
hey thanks very much